What I have depicted
right over here
is a fairly typical
Sn2 reaction.
We see this hydroxide.
It substitutes this bromine.
It becomes a hydroxyl group.
The bromine takes-- so it gives
this pair to form this bond.
Then this bond in both of those
electrons go to the bromine,
and now that becomes
the bromide anion.
So we've seen this
multiple times.
But what I want to really
study in this video,
is what happens to the
handedness of these molecules
or to the molecule
right over here,
I guess you could
say to the substrate,
although obviously, one group
gets substituted with another.
So let's name this
thing right over here.
So if we start counting at
this carbon-- 1, 2, 3, 4.
Four-carbon backbone,
it is all single bonds.
This is a butane.
And then it has a bromine
at the number 2 carbon.
So this is 2-bromobutane.
So let me write
this-- 2-bromobutane.
And then after this
reaction, it becomes--
so once again, we still
have four carbons,
but now, instead
of a bromyl group,
we have a hydroxyl group,
which makes this an alcohol.
So instead of just
calling it butane,
we would now call
it butanol because
of this hydroxyl
group right over here.
Butanol right here,
and the hydroxyl group
is attached to the 1, 2.
So this is 1, 2 carbon,
So this is 2-butanol.
But what I really
want to think about
is the chirality,
or the handedness.
And we see here, this
carbon, in both cases,
it is a chiral carbon.
The four things
that it is bonded to
are all different-- a bromine,
a CH3, a hydrogen, and then
you could kind of view
this as a ethyl group.
It's bonded to two
carbons right over here.
So these are all different.
So we can think
about its handedness.
Same here, bonded to
four different things.
So whenever you're
thinking about chirality,
the convention is take
the thing that it's
bonded to that has the
lowest atomic number
and put that in the back.
Well, hydrogen has the
lowest atomic number
out of all of these four things.
So you could imagine that
being put into the back.
And in fact, it's
already drawn that way.
So it's kind of going
into the screen.
So we'll focus on these
three things right out here.
And the convention is,
start with the thing that
has the highest atomic number.
And the thing that has
the highest atomic number
is the bromine out
of the four things
that this chiral
carbon is bonded to,
and then go in the
order-- and then
rotate in the order of where the
next highest atomic number is.
Well, you say, well, you have
a carbon there, a carbon there.
They have the same
atomic number.
But then you go to what it's
bonded to for the tie breaker.
And this is bonded
to three hydrogens.
This is bonded to two hydrogens
and then another carbon.
So this extra carbon breaks
that atomic number tiebreaker
so we go in this direction.
We go in this direction
right over here.
And the way I think about it
is what's happening at the top.
Well, we're moving to the right.
We are moving in the
clockwise directions.
So we would call this
R-- R-2-bromobutane.
And we have other videos, where
we go into much more detail
about naming chiral molecules.
But I like to think about
what's happening at the top.
R, my little mnemonic in
my head is R for right.
R-2-bromobutane is
right over here.
Now let's think about
what's going on over here.
Once again, put the
hydrogen in the back.
It has the lowest atomic number.
And so we'll focus on the
carbons and the oxygen.
Out of carbons
and oxygen, oxygen
has the highest atomic number.
And then we'll move in the
direction of the next highest.
Well, once again, the
CH2CH3, the C's have
the same atomic number,
but then the tiebreaker
is when you think about
what it's bonded to.
This is bonded to
another carbon,
while this is all hydrogens.
So we move in this direction,
or counterclockwise direction.
In our chirality
naming convention
is we would say
S, S for sinister.
S-2-butanol.
Now, the whole reason why I
went through this exercise
is to show you that it is
Sn2 reaction, the handedness,
the chirality has
changed for the molecule.
You can imagine that
this-- if you imagine
that over here
this 2-bromobutane,
if this was an umbrella,
where the bromine is kind
of the handle and this is kind
of an upward-turned umbrella,
all of a sudden the
nucleophile comes in,
the leaving group pops off,
and then the umbrella pops off
or the umbrella goes
in the other direction.
It has kind of changed.
Because the nucleophile's
coming from the left side,
the leaving group is
leaving from the right,
it has changed its handedness.
And the reason why
this is interesting
is, well, OK, it's
an SN2 reaction.
This now changed.
I went from R to S.
In an Sn1 reaction,
as we'll see, because
in an Sn1, reaction
the nucleophile
leaves on its own,
And then the nucleo-- sorry,
the leaving group leaves
on its own, and then the
nucleophile comes in,
and it could come
in from any side.
So with an Sn1
reaction, you get a mix.
You might switch
handedness or you might not
switch handedness.
So the whole point
of this video is
to get you a little bit more--
thinking a little bit more
about this about the
stereochemistry chemistry
and the handedness
of Sn2 reactions.